police have launched a concerted effort
to tackle off-road motorcycle riders and
other nuisance behavior in woodland and
open spaces around the rochford district
local offices supported by a special
mountain bike squad and officers and
horses from the mounted section will
patrol woods country parks and private
farmland in a crackdown on anti-social
behavior
they will carry out stop checks on
motorcycles and quad bikes being ridden
illegally and will have the power to
seize vehicles from persistent offenders
the operation will be focused on new
england woods hockley woods gusted
hallwoods cherry orchard country park
edwards hall park fleming's farm and
grove woods
sergeant steve joins from the hockley
neighborhood policing team said the
irresponsible behaviour of the nuisance
motorcyclist is endangering horse riders
dog walkers and others using the woods
legitimately
they will often spend several hours
riding off-road and are literally riding
roughshod over other residents enjoyment
of the environment
we will deal robustly with anyone
behaving in such an anti-social manner
and i would ask anyone who sees bikers
riding in the woods or vehicles
offloading bikes to take a note of their
index number or any other details and
call us
police also have evidence of vandals
deliberately starting fires in woods and
fields and causing explosions by burning
aerosol cans further endangering
legitimate uses and putting unnecessary
strain on hard-pressed emergency
services
sergeant joyne said their foolish
behavior not only jeopardizes their own
safety and that of other people but also
represents a real threat to the woods
themselves
we are determined to stamp out this
nuisance and the availability of our
cycling squad allows us greater
accessibility over rough terrain it's
harder for people to get away from us
now
help keep your area safe with seven and
a half million members nationally
neighborhood watch plays a key role in
helping reduce opportunities for crime
and anti-social behavior it works to
improve community safety and reduce or
prevent crime by developing close
liaison between households and the
police and by promoting crime prevention
and home security advice
though not run by the police
neighborhood watch works in partnership
with them by letting police know of
anything suspicious in their area
members can help deter would-be burglars
and vandals
neighbourhood watch is also about
building communities spirit and good
relations among residents and is a
popular way for people of all ages to
get involved in making their area safe
membership of a neighborhood watch
scheme has other benefits too members
not only learn more about crime
prevention and home security to help
keep their property and possessions safe
but as a result may also qualify for a
discount on their house insurance
the rochford district neighborhood watch
team is looking to recruit keen
volunteers to become neighborhood watch
coordinators
if you would like details about setting
up a scheme please email nhw rayleigh at
essex dot pnn dot police dot uk
or contact mike hooper chairman of
rochefort district nhw on
zero one two six eight double seven zero
five one nine or care of the
neighborhood watch off israeli police
station 119 high street raleigh ss6 7qb
you can also take a look at the rochford
district neighborhood watch website to
find out more details about the scheme
the website address is www dot r r n w
dot c o m e z e dot com
neighborhood watch in association with
rochefort district community safety
partnership has extended its successful
and free bike security tagging campaign
program to local schools
mike hooper chairman of the neighborhood
watch and clive mayhew essex watch
coordinator for the rochford district
recently visited king edmund school with
deputy head sue nickel where more than
20 pupils took the opportunity to have
the security devices fitted to their
bikes
neighborhood watch by numbers
the rochford district neighborhood watch
team currently has 180 watch
coordinators covering 4451
properties across the rochford district
they also issue a newsletter once every
three months
the rochford district community safety
partnership the csp has pitched in to
help provide a soccer skills course for
young people in wakering
they have contributed 1
920 pound for a qualified coach to leave
twice weekly soccer sessions for
teenagers in a six-month pilot scheme
organised by the wakering young people's
community project
some 40 young people regularly attend
the project's team cafe twice a week
where football is among activities
available
the chair of the project's trustees
hillary wilson said the young people and
not only the boys have frequently
requested a coach to help them improve
their skills and to show them ways to
keep fit
this pilot scheme will give us an
opportunity to decide if a coach should
be engaged permanently and we're
grateful for the support of the csb in
helping fund this
vice chair of the csp chief inspector
glenn wesley said the teen cafe provides
a safe place for young people to enjoy
themselves and make new friends
it offers the diversionary activities
that young people enjoy and are
enthusiastic about like football and
which encourage a positive attitude and
social responsibility
we are wholeheartedly behind initiatives
like this
and the csp has recently received a
number of complaints about intrusive
telephone calls from sales companies
attempting to sell anything from loft
insulation to fitted kitchens
residents can do something to deter this
cold calling by registering their
telephone number with the telephone
preference service that's the tps
the tps maintains a central opt-out
register of people who do not wish to
receive
unsolicited sales or marketing telephone
calls
it is a legal requirement that companies
do not make such calls to numbers
registered with the tps
the service is free and once the number
has been registered it becomes effective
in 28 days
and to register call the tps
registration line on 0845
070707
or go to www.tpsonline.org.uk
and if you're receiving sales and
marketing voice recorded messages and
you have not given prior consent to
receive such messages you can ask the
marketeer to stop sending these
they are legally obliged to act upon
your request
however if you still receive calls or it
is not possible to ask the company to
stop sending these types of messages
contact the information commissioner's
office the ico
the government body responsible for
enforcing the regulations
for more information visit w w w dot
dot uk
or phone their helpline on zero one six
two five
five four five
seven four five
rochford district matters is edited by
patrick john and produced by rochford
district council who can be found at 3
to 19 south street rochford ss4 1bw
their telephone number is zero one seven
zero two five four six three six six and
their website is at www.rochford.gov
dot uk
the paper is printed by shaman and
company limited
and that brings us to the end of this
edition which was recorded by volunteers
from the rayleigh rochford and castle
point talking newspapers for the blind
at their studio in rochford